le média américain vultcher vient de
révéler que les notes du site rotten
tomato sont manipulées au-delà de cette
affaire particulière ça va nous amener à
nous interroger sur la façon dont se
forgent nos avis artistiques et les
conséquences que peuvent avoir un
système de notation hégémonique bonjour
à tous et toutes j'espère que vous allez
bien on est parti pour un petit épisode
de sociol Quick et je vais commencer par
détailler un petit peu l'affaire
notamment pour ceux qui ne connaîtrai
pas le site Rotten Tomatoes c'est un
agrégateur de critique qui attribue à
chaque film et série une note sur 100 en
fait pour chaque critique qu'on récupère
on regarde s'il s'agit d'une critique
positive ou négative et puis après on
calcule en pourcentage de critique
positive qui donne accès à différents
paliers de fraîcheur par exemple le
premier film Matrix avec ses 83 % d'avis
positif est dans la catégorie des
certified fraîche parce que on est
au-dessus des 75 % mais si on regarde
matrix résurrection on est qu'à 63 %.
donc on a encore une tomate fraîche hein
parce que on est au-dessus des 60 % mais
si on regarde matrix 3 révolution on
tombe à 34 % hein donc on est dans la la
catégorie tomate pourri comme pour tous
les films en dessous des 60 % de critiqu
positives donc déjà on peut dire que
c'est un agrégateur très grossier hein
parce que on a aucune nuance sur la
critique soit elle est positive soit
elle est négative et on a que trois
paliers différents mais surtout elle
nivèle complètement tous les avis
critiques c'est-à-dire que dans la
catégorie critique professionnelle on va
mettre au même niveau une critique des
Cahiers du Cinéma de valeurs actuelles
ou de cheminées magazine après on sait
pas si ça se trouve ces critiques sont
peut-être des gros bangers hein et ce
que révèle l'article c'est quand de 2018
une agence de marketing a manipulé les
chiffres pour faire gonfler la note du
film Ophelia qui est une espèce de
relecture féministe de hamelette avec
desir idley ce qui s'est passé c'est que
à sa sortie le film n'avait que 13
critiques professionnelles avec une note
de 46 % donc bien du côté pourri de la
tomate et l'agence de pub a donc payé
des nouvelles critiques 50 dollars pour
qu'il donne des avis positifs sur le
film et ça a effectivement permis de
faire monter la note à 62 %. donc c'est
pas ouf non plus mais suffisant pour
avoir le logo tomate fraîche on peut
quand même s'étonner sur le fait fait
que ce soit si peu cher d'acheter des
critiques de cinéma et c'est sûrement
révélateur de pas mal de précarité dans
le milieu on vit dans une saucisse tout
ça tout ça mais outre cet exemple très
criant d'achat de critique he l'article
pointe aussi des manipulations plus
habituelles comme le fait de
sursélectionner les critiques qui vont
aller voir le film en avant-première un
des derniers exemples en date c'est le
film The flash qu'on a fait voir
uniquement à des fans zous de DC pour
que le film commence son exploitation en
salle avec une note de 95 % donc un bon
petit boost he pour la première semaine
d'exploitation depuis on est retombé à 6
63 % maintenant que d'autres critiques
ont pu voir le film et dire que c'était
quand même pas terrible terrible du coup
on peut se demander pourquoi les studios
hollywoodiens qui normalement ont des
agences marketing font des Bones
annonces et cetera prennent la peine de
manipuler un site de notation comme
Roton tomatoose et pour bien comprendre
ça il va falloir examiner un peu plus en
détail certaines particularités
économiques des biens culturel on est
[Musique]
parti
comment on choisit un film à regarder la
question a l'air simple mais en fait pas
tant que ça je suis sûr qu'à vous aussi
ça vous arrive parfois de passer plus de
temps à choisir un film qu'à vraiment le
regarder et ce simple petit problème du
choix de film a pendant longtemps était
une des bêtes noires des économiste et
oui parce que à la base c'est bien
l'économie qui s'est spécialisé dans
l'étude de nos choix de consommation et
pour faire ça ils ont mis au point un
modèle super pratique c'est celui de
l'agent rationnel maximisateur sous
contrainte en gros en fonction de mes
préférences et de mon budget je choisis
toujours l'option de consommation qui
m'apporte le plus de satisfaction mais
ça ça veut dire qu'on suppose que je
suis capable de prévoir à l'avance la
satisfaction que je vais ressentir à la
consommation de tel ou tel bien et c'est
vrai que en général ça marche quand même
assez bien j'arrive à peu près à prévoir
la satisfaction que j'aurai à consommer
une pomme une chaise ou un Tapy tong
j'ai absolument ont besoin de ça mais il
y a une catégorie de biens pour lesquels
le modèle ne marche plus du tout les
œuvres d'art ou les biens culturels de
façon générale et oui tant que je n'ai
pas vu un film je ne peux pas savoir à
l'avance quelle satisfaction il va
m'apporter je suis en situation
d'incertitude et du coup bah c'est
compliqué de faire un choix rationnel il
y en a qui règlent le problème en
consomant toujours les mêmes trucs en
boucle he comme ça ils savent qu'ils
seront pas déçus mais il y a quand même
des moments où on est obligé d'exprimer
une préférence et c'est là qu'on va
devoir essayer de déployer des modèles
explicatifs alors l'un des premiers à
avoir essayé de régler ce problème de
l'incertitude des choix dans un
environnement de bien fortement
différencié c'est l'économiste Kalin
lencaster dans un article de 1966 l'idée
de l'encaster c'est que en fait quand on
fait un choix de consommation on ne
regarderait pas le produit dans son
ensemble mais on serait capable de le
découper en plein de petites
caractéristiques qui elles nous sont
connues et du coup qu'on va essayer de
maximiser par exemple pour un film ça
peut être le genre le réalisateur les
acteurs la franchise tous les éléments
qui le constituent par exemple c'est
vrai que je ne peux pas véritablement
savoir à l'avance si je vais aimer ou
pas le film Expandables 4 mais en
regardant les acteurs au casting la
subtilité de l'affiche et les trois
films précédents j'arrive quand même à
me faire une petite idée d'ailleurs il
semble bien que les studios de cinéma
ont clairement compris qu'on utilise
tous les éléments à notre disposition
pour essayer de réduire l'incertitude
sur la qualité des produits parce que on
nous propose de plus en plus des films
qui s'inscrivent dans des univers connus
de fait si un film est une suite ou
s'inscrit dans une franchise bah ça nous
donne clairement des informations sur le
fait qu'on l' apprpréciera ou non et
donc c'est un choix moins risqué pour
nous d'où la quantité de suite remake
reboot prequel sequel spinoff et autres
multiverses d'œuvres déjà connu qui
permettent au studio de se sécuriser une
fan base minimale quand ils sortent un
film avec évidemment tous les effets
pervers que ça peut
provoquerain
conard et l'encaster va même plus loin
parce que selon lui on serait capable de
décomposer précisément chaque
caractéristiques d'un bien culturel pour
les mettre dans notre calcul de
préférence par exemple on prend le genre
le réalisateur les acteurs la franchise
le studio le budget et cetera et on
pondère comment chaque caractéristique
influence habituellement notre jugement
pourtant c'est quand même assez
difficile de penser qu'on puisse
calculer ça aussi précisément parce que
le plus souvent hein quand on condne aus
préférences on manque le contrefactuel
par exemple qu'est-ce que ça donnerait
si le film The Dark Knight n'avait pas
été réalisé par Christopher Nolan est-ce
qu'on l'aurait aimé ou pas ou si il
n'avait pas s au casting ou si la band
son avait été faite par John Williams au
lieu de anzimer on aura jamais la
réponse à ces questions et du coup on
sera jamais vraiment capable d'évaluer
l'effet de chacune de ces variables cela
dit on a parfois des expériences dites
naturelles qui peuvent permettre
d'évaluer certaines de ces
caractéristiques par exemple vous savez
probablement que Henry caville quitte la
série The Witcher à l'issue de la saison
3 pour être remplacé par liamenswst dans
le rôle du Witcher donc ici on a un
produit culturel dont les
caractéristiques restent à peu près
identiques à part une seule la l'acteur
principal ça nous met dans des
conditions idéales pour tester l'impact
de cette caractéristique si la saison 4
de The Witcher se plante alors Netflix
pourra savoir que parmi toutes les
caractéristiques qui composaient la
série la catégorie Henry caville au
casting bah était en fait fortement
valorisé par le public et je vous cache
pas que j'en tomberai pas de ma chaise
si c'était le cas mais même dans ce
cas-là il y a quand même des limites au
raisonnement parce que on sera jamais
capable d'isoler parfaitement l'effet
propre du départ d'enry caville d'autres
effets he qui peuvent aussi jouer sur
Damours de la série par conséquent le
modèle de Lancaster il a quand même pas
mal été critiqué parce que s'il fait
bien le constat que le modèle d'économie
standard ne marche pas sur les biens
culturels en fait il finit par balayer
le truc en nous disant bah finalement
les biens culturels sont pas si
singuliers que ça on peut les décomposé
en plein de petites catégories
identifiables et appliquer le modèle de
l'agent rtionnel tout pareil comme on a
l'habitude de faire et plusieurs
chercheurs ont donc montré que ben en
fait on n'est pas vraiment capable de
faire ce travail de décomposition de nos
préférences de façon aussi précise l'un
de ses chercheurs c'est le sociologue C
carpique qui publie en 2007 son livre
l'économie des singularités dans lequel
il soulligne que les biens culturels
sont par définition
incomensurable c'est-à-dire qu'on ne
peut pas les réduire à une addition de
caractéristiques identifiables il
soulligne bien que oui hein des petites
caractéristiques permettent de réduire
l'incertitude mais dans une certaine
mesure seulement par exemple si je m'y
connais bien en 20 et que j'hésite entre
deux bouteilles ben je peux regarder le
terroir le sépage le millésim le château
où il a été produit le nombre d'années
passées en Futcha et cetera et cetera
tout ça va effectivement me donner des
informations mais bon à un moment de
donné si je veux vraiment savoir lequel
des deux je préfère bah il y a pas
d'autre solution il faut que je les
ouvre et que je goûte on peut pas sortir
de là c'est le principe de ces biens que
Lucien carpiic appelle des singularités
et son travail consiste à montrer
l'importance de ce qu'il appelle les
instances de jugement qui ont
précisément pour but de dissiper
l'opacité du marché et de nous aider à
faire des choix par exemple pour le vin
on a le fameux guide par cœur qui met
des notes pour distinguer les meilleurs
vins et d'ailleurs ça se traduit
immédiatement par les prix avec un quasi
doublement voire triplement du prix de
vente pour les 20 qui ont les notes les
plus élevées je suis sûr que vous aussi
vous vous fiez au petit macaron là
médaillé d'or au grand concours de vin
de pitonchepon écrepin et ça nous permet
d'orienter nos choix quand on se
retrouve démuni devant le rayon vin du
carrefour par exemple cette bouteille
que j'ai acheté l'autre jour là je l'ai
prise uniquement parce qu'il y a le
petit macaron médaille d'or Paris 2022
c'est le seul élément qui m'a orienté
dans mon choix il y a aucune autre
raison pour laquelle j'aurais choisi
cette bouteille là plutôt qu'une autre
aucune bon Lucien carpique met donc en
évidence cinq grands types d'instan de
jugement qui nous permettent de nous
aider dans nos choix les réseaux les
appellations les cyéron les classements
et les Confluences donc autrement dit
les réseaux c'est le bouche à oreille
les appellations c'est les labels comme
Grand Cru Supérieur ou les aousé pour
les fromages les Cicéron ça va être les
critiques ou les guides qui représentent
une autorité symbolique donc typiquement
le guide Parker pour les vins mais le
guide Michelin pour les restaurants
c'est typiquement ça aussi les
classements ça va être les prix ou les
palmarès donc là typiquement pour les
films on va avoir les Oscars les César
la palme d'oracan par exemple et enfin
les Confluences c'est les techniques de
mise en valeur sur les lieux de vente
même comme le fait d'être en tête de
gondolle par exemple ou pour les livres
d'être en facing sur l'étagère à titre
d'exemple complètement pris au hasard
une petite illustration avec mon livre
en facing dans une librairie de citres
évidemment il est totalement disponible
vous avez totalement la possibilité de
l'acheter si vous voulez apprendre plein
de trucs sur la pop culture et les
sciences sociales sans rentrer trop dans
le détail he Lucien carpique montre
notamment que pour le marcher des
variétés c'est bien souvent les
dispositifs de classement qui ont
tendance à être les plus prescripteurs
et ils reposent sur ce qu'on appelle
l'effet hit parade c'est quelque chose
de bien connu he mais dans les espaces
très concurrentiels comme le sont les
mondes de l'art on a souvent un modèle
du Winner tes all le gagnant prend tout
où on va avoir une petite différence de
qualité qui va provoquer d'énormes
différences dans les résultats c'est
particulièrement le cas dans le cinéma
où la moitié des entrées sont réalisé
par seulement 5 % des films sortis c'est
aussi évidemment le cas en musique hein
où le Top 50 domine très largement tout
le
[Musique]
reste d'ailleurs je viens de vous dire
qu'une petite différence de qualité
pouvait provoquer de gros écarts dans
les résultats mais en fait les
recherches en psychologie social ont
même montré que le succès ne repose même
pas vraiment sur la qualité réelle de
ces œuvres je pense notamment à une
expérience où on demandait à des
personnees de voter pour leur musique
préférée parmi une liste de 48 chansons
originales et à chaque fois on remarque
que c'est la musique qui engrange un peu
plus de survote au tout début qui
devient la préférée de toutes les autres
et de très très loin et quand on répète
l'expérience plusieurs fois on voit que
c'est à chaque fois une musique
différente qui arrive en tête ce qui
montre que le jugement social ne dépend
pas seulement des qualités intrinsèques
de la musique mais plutôt de la preuve
sociale générée par le comportement et
l'écoute des autres utilisateurs je vous
renvoie vers cette vidéo de hacking
social pour une présentation beaucoup
plus détaillée de cette expérience et de
ses implications et du coup on comprend
maintenant pour pourquoi le site rotten
tomatoos a pu prendre autant
d'importance dans ces dernières années
il s'agit d'un dispositif de jugement
qui permet de classer des singularité et
qui joue aussi bien sur le régime de
l'opinion experte avec la note des
critiques mais aussi sur le régime de
l'opinion commune pour sa note du public
alors comme on l'a dit le système de
notation a plein de défauts il gomme
complètement les nuances entre les
niveaux d'expertise des critiques et
surtout il résume les avis de façon
binaire positif ou négatif mais ce qu'il
perd en nuance il le gagne en clarté
parce que la note qui résulte est d'une
simplicité extrême et il devient très
facile pour le public de faire des
classements entre les films ce n'est
donc pas étonnant que ce site est pris
autant d'importance et qu'il soit de
plus en plus utilisé par le public pour
se forger une première impression sur un
film et du coup à partir du moment où
avoir une bonne note sur Roton tomatoose
permet de faire plus d'entrée bah les
studios sont fatalement incités à
maximiser cette note du coup la note
rotent tomatose cesse d'être simplement
une mesure de la qualité d'un film film
mais devient un objectif à atteindre et
là on retombe sur quelque chose dont je
vous ai déjà parlé l'année dernière
l'effet Cobra quand une mesure devient
un objectif elle cesse d'être une bonne
mesure et je vous invite bien sûr à
aller voir et revoir la vidéo si vous
voulez en savoir plus sur l'effet Cobra
et les côtés obscurs de la mesure c'est
notamment la raison pour laquelle Lucien
carpiic insiste fortement sur le fait
que l'efficacité d'un dispositif de
jugement repose fortement sur la
confiance qu'on lui accorde le guide
Michelin par exemple communique beaucoup
sur son impartialité sur son absence de
lien d'intérêt et sur les fait que leurs
critiques sont incorruptibles qui vont
dans le restaurant incognito tout ça
pour que on garde une certaine confiance
dans leur expertise il y a donc fort à
parier que Ben le niveau de confiance
accordé au cite Roton tomatos risque
d'être fortement ébranlé par l'affaire
qui vient d'éclater et qu'il cesse
d'être autant utilisé par les personnes
qui ont envie de se faire des avis sur
un film mais paradoxalement si rotten
tomatoos cesse d'être une référence
contournable il va peut-être sortir du
radar des studios hollywoodiens qui du
coup essaieront moins de l'influencer et
du coup il finira peut-être par
redevenir quelque chose de
fiable on retombe sur l'une des grandes
difficultés de la mesure et de l'analyse
en Scien sociale c'est que les mesures
peuvent être performatives et influencer
l'objet même qu'on est en train
d'étudier ce qui doit nous enjoindre à
beaucoup de prudence
épistémique cet épisode de sociol Quick
est maintenant terminé j'espère qu'il
vous aura plu n'hésitez pas à devenir
vous-même des instances de jugement et à
partager cette vidéo sur les réseaux à
mettre des pouces en l'air des
commentaires bref tout ce qui peut
permettre de réduire l'incertitude du
public et des algorithmes sur sa qualité
et donner envie au plus de public
possible de la regarder moi je vous fais
des gros bisous et à très vite
Ciao